joining me now is Tulsa gabbard former
congresswoman and presidential candidate
and army reservist Tulsi um thanks for
being with us tonight how many Americans
thanks Laura really are going to have to
suffer before
there is some type of accountability
within this Administration for its
repeated failures failure after failure
no one ever gets fired except that guy
who stole the lady's luggage
and that that right there is the tragedy
here Laura at this point none of us
should be surprised at their lack of
care and compassion even after this
disaster for the people there in
Palestine Ohio or those who are facing
similar disasters across the country
they have shown us already that they do
not care about us they don't respect us
so much that they think we're stupid and
continue to lie to us and make up
stories to cover their own backside
they could have taken action to prevent
this you look at the corporate side you
look at Norfolk Southern they make
billions of dollars every year we should
be asking from them hey why is it that
you're still running unsafe archaic
technology in your train systems ask the
Biden Administration hey you knew Pete
butterjudge said oh well there's a
thousand trains that derail every year
if you know that what are you doing
about it what could you have done to
potentially prevent this absolute
catastrophe putting the lives of these
families their loved ones their kids
kids their their pets their animals at
risk here and that's really the question
that we need to ask of those who are
responsible they're so arrogant they
think that they're special they're Above
the Law they're above approach they're
above accountability they clearly don't
care about us they think they can get
away with anything we have to demand
more we have to demand this
accountability we have to demand that
those who are in these positions are
actually doing their job to take care of
the American people a lot of this
reminds me a little bit of of the opioid
crisis Laura where you've got all these
big pharmaceutical companies making a
lot of money off the lives and suffering
of the American people how many of them
are in jail right now
I can't think of a single one and so
these people at Norfolk Southern people
in the Biden Administration they look to
that and they think hey we're going to
get away with this uh without a scrape
on our back and and we we cannot allow
that to happen we can't
um now Buddha judge criticized Trump
for some of his deregulatory moves in
this case they didn't even apply to what
was happening in this train but the
department of transportation's most
recent regulatory agenda which lists all
plan proposed and final rules does not
include
at the ECP breaking rule which
everybody's been talking about again
they invoke it now but it's not
something they ever
have talked about before or even
attempted to pass the irregulation
yeah you know you know what's
interesting when you played Pete
bootage's or pointed out his comment
that well you know we're we're doing our
best with with what we are allowed to do
or permitted to do when it's convenient
for them and their agenda they'll pass
executive orders they'll get you know
the ATF or some other department to you
know pass what is essentially a law to
make the changes that they want but now
again instead of doing the right thing
taking ownership and taking
responsibility and saying hey we screwed
up here's what we should have done and
here's what we're going to fix it
instead again they're making up the
rules as they go along because they
really only care about themselves Pete
butterjudge only cares about himself and
whatever his Ambitions are in the future
and this just it hurts my heart for all
of those who are watching at home who
live along Rail lines in this country
who are concerned for the safety and
well-being of their family the next time
a train goes by and they've got to sit
there and wonder is what is in those
rail cars will I and my family be safe
or will we be the next ones who are
suffering like our fellow Americans are
in Palestine Ohio today
and Chelsea if there wasn't a media
outcry albeit a little bit late about
this
do you think they would have even I mean
really done much at all it seems like
they were as I said in the angle fairly
unfazed by this it they would not and
this is not a guess we know that they
would not because they are barely barely
doing anything right now throwing a few
pennies at these families who are
suffering and worried if they're going
to have long-term cancer is such a
freaking insult to them so no if you and
others were not drawing the spotlight on
them and their hypocrisy and their
conflict of interest and their
selfishness these families would be even
worse off than they are today
Tulsi great to see you tonight thank you
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else